hello and welcome to this video a little
al-khaimah
sorry probably this is irritating sound
but should do this before the video so
the Queen's Gambit not playing the
London yet you never know might do so in
the future so we got a Queens gambit
declined exchange variation the cards
but yeah Bishop a5 is nowadays alone
they they also play lots of night aged
fives
it's a that's uncommon or am I should I
have played Quincy - huh maybe I should
have played Quincy - they're never
really thought about the move order
they're all that much but Quincy to
might be more precise yeah okay I'm not
really unhappy with my position but
still a little bit uncommon - to have
this kind of structure okay so
king of one King G - where is my idea
but I don't quite know what I should do
next one idea could be to play d5 at the
right moment but we will see about that
if he goes c5 now I will probably go d5
yeah you're not going to play g5 in this
kind of position I cannot so think about
playing g4 here it's interesting it's a
bit odd it's interesting if it takes it
Queeny for oops that should be not too
bad for me I think
g6 not hanging but okay that's
interesting but now Knight e4 is
something that could be a factor I just
I just don't know where to put the Queen
probably there is no very good square
around it's not that interesting I don't
know if I take it I mean I have the idea
to just play King g3 then I don't like
that his Knight comes back into the game
completely ignored the simpleness
that is a very stupid missile rupee aid
I'm not playing a good game here that's
not not at all
yeah maybe it's still okay but I'm not
happy with my plane intending rook d7
and now this one is not possible okay I
can take at 94 so so much good may be
here before 95 really gets played
nice 92d form that's what I should do
probably
yeah that's what I should do centralize
the knight on c3 is a stupid piece
maybe maybe taking with the King and
playing 94 is more interesting if I take
and play Knight c5 maybe rook c5 h5 is
pretty much doomed okay
that's not a move I thought would be
would be considered
yes I'm winning upon now cannot save
both aged five and seven so you know we
have a bit of time you five not sure
that I just want to grab the material
and I can try to make more of this
but check kingi five and it's not that
great okay
I will win g4 hmm I completely
miscounted this completely Jesus
I cannot believe I'm losing this game
that's really crazy let's totally crazy
from you've completely winning ending
[Music]
I'm losing it that that's completely
insane you have a winning ending and and
you lose it that's it's that stupid
really stupid I mean yeah this is just a
win that it's not about no care and then
here's a we know whatever I mean losing
is crazy I totally miss counted that
yeah I mean you this is painful
hereafter move like a caged a to lose a
game but okay it's just my own fault
before yeah whatever yeah you can also
play for control here with the four and
so on
so I should probably go back onto the
first strain gasps yeah SSS totally
idiotic move I mean there is this rule
of thumb to stop the porn the first
possible opportunity but here this is
not completely not applying here here
here maybe it's a draw
maybe it's a draw the losing is just
completely idiotic that's really
terrible there's this it's still it
should be a win but yet it's play this
plus a million so what did I do wrong
here not be one I of course why do I
take just put it here the deaths that's
rook takes me three as a totally idiotic
move crazy sometimes this is just a
completely simple win and he it should
be a draw with King f5 via yeah you have
to bodycheck King f6 and then you draw
oh my god when I was it that was one of
the most stupid losses it is about I
mean I had again recently where mister
made in one and when I was a piece up
this is even more idea more ridiculous
it's a disgusting anyway thanks thanks a
lot for watching